bastante corta la viabilidad que tiene
este juicio político de prosperar en
washington y es que a pesar de que los
la defensa de donald trump fue bastante
floja bastante criticada ayer y que los
demócratas pues tienen bastantes pruebas
a través de vídeos a través de audios y
a través de documentos pues son muy
pocos los republicanos los que quieren
arriesgarse los senadores republicanos
que quieren arriesgarse a votar en
contra de donald trump porque eso podría
afectarles cualquier interés de
reelección que tengan en sus estados así
que en el caso del marco rubio por
ejemplo de la florida muchos han optado
por decir que sí donald trump va a ser
juzgado que sea juzgado como un
ciudadano común y corriente y no como un
expresidente por eso muchos de ellos
podrían votar en contra de él